[Music]
one u.s senator shining a light on
statewide hypocrisy
our next guest proposed bill would
require
any states implementing vaccine
passports to also
mandate voter id north dakota center
kevin kramer joins us right now senator
you can't have one without the other can
you
well it seems pretty obvious to me brian
i mean i've never
ceased to be amazed at how easily
democrats are willing to give up their
personal
private health care records just so they
can you know eat at a restaurant
in manhattan but then resist the
requirement to demonstrate you are who
you say you are
to do something as important as casting
a vote for president of the united
states
and so what my bill intends to do is is
shine that spotlight of hypocrisy which
by the way
hypocrisy is not exactly new in politics
but this is a pretty extreme
version of it so this is really a
message for bill de blasio because we're
the first city
in the country that is saying you have
to show a vaccine passport in order to
eat in
indoors go to a gym go to a show so have
you heard from bill de blasio are we
going to now show an id when we vote
here
well i haven't heard from bill de blasio
and i expect that you won't but i do
expect that he's going to have to answer
some
pretty obvious questions about this
gross intrusion on people's
personal information and i think this
this is really
to me a frightening situation where the
american people have been
asked to do something like demonstration
that is highly personal and private
information right
and of course senator it's all about
they're trying to get
right now i think the number is just
under 50 percent just under 50 percent
of americans have been
immunized against covet the
administration
realizes to get to co to herd of
immunity these days you got to be
70 80 85 percent the number seems to be
changing
and so they're just trying they're
pulling out all the stops trying to get
everybody vaccinated so a couple of
things
steve that bother me about that first of
all there's been no credit given to the
fact that many people
have have uh you know antibodies because
they've had the
the disease itself right and there's no
credit for that the other thing is
it's counterproductive the american
people are not ill informed about this
there is lots of information out there
self-governed people
are very you know capable of being
self-informed and and when you start
bullying or or harassing people
that's very counterproductive people
consult their doctors
make their own decision for them and
their family what's going on with this
infrastructure bill 2
702 pages they need uh 10 republicans to
vote for it
uh it is going to add to the deficit it
is not paid for it's going to be 256
billion dollars to it according to the
cbo
how do you stand senator well i support
it
for a couple of reasons brian first of
all the cbo score is not
the only thing that matters when it
comes to the pay for cbo is
barred from scoring things like
unemployment insurance benefits that are
being returned or repurposing
already appropriated funds through the
cares act and other
uh other relief packages
so it actually in my view i'm very
comfortable with the pay fors but beyond
that
even if it's 25 billion dollars a year
of
expense we just spent 7 trillion dollars
on things that produce nothing now
important don't get me wrong
to to people's individual economies but
an asset like infrastructure has as its
primary purpose the movement of goods
and services in our economy
it's an asset that returns value to our
economy and ultimately
to the taxpayer so i still think it's a
very good and i think a high priority
and important
doesn't function does it pass the senate
today i believe it'll pass if not today
tomorrow
you mentioned senator haggarty's
objection to to moving quickly to the
amendments
he has every right to do that if it
takes a day longer
then we just stay here through a sunday
and we get her done tomorrow night if we
can't get it done tonight or to or
or even sunday night if not tomorrow
night senator thanks so much appreciate
it kevin kramer